ours is the fury
these are the words of the black stag of
Baratheon a Battle Cry echoed throughout
the land in Rebellion when I Robert
Baratheon the first of his name seized
the Iron Throne from the Mad King
heiress Targaryen ending a dynasty
nearly 300 years old
house Baratheon was born in the wars of
Conquest when aegon the dragon invaded
Westeros
aegon sent his Commander Oris Baratheon
to take Storm's end
argilac The Arrogant the last of the
storm Kings foolishly left the safety of
his stronghold and met the Baratheon
warlord in open battle
argalak was soundly defeated and Oris
took his lands his Holdings and his
daughter
Horus was said to be a half-brother to
aegon Targaryen okay guys house of the
Dragon is based on George R Martin's
book Fire and Blood and now you can
listen to it for free with a notable
trial using a link which you can find in
the description of this video all you
have to do is go to the description
click the link sign up for a free
audible trial and choose Fire and Blood
audiobook go and listen to a complete
Targaryen history including the current
and future events of House of the Dragon
for free
If This Were true a little Blood Of The
Dragon mingled with that of the Stag in
those days
the seat of house Baratheon is Storm's
end a legendary keep raised in the age
of Heroes
it overlooks shipbreakers Bay where
legend has it that Duran the first Storm
King raised the keep with the aid of
bran the Builder of house Stark forging
a Century's long connection with the
stormlands and the North
after aegon's conquest of the Seven
Kingdoms the baratheons remained loyal
enough to the crown while Targaryen
kings came and went
but loyalty has its limits
when rhaegar Targaryen Harris's vile sun
and air abducted lyanna Stark I
betrothed my beloved
it was time to act
we raised our banners Baratheon Stark
John Aaron and the tullys united in
Rebellion against rhaegar and his father
the Mad King
we were victorious and took the iron
throne
that bit of dragon blood in my veins
came in well as it made me a distant
relation to the Targaryen Dynasty blood
of my long-lost ancestor Oris
the truth of it is
I took it
Tarth has lulled many a novice sailor
into complacency our Lush Island sits on
calm Blue Water like an emerald set into
a sapphire he would never guess that
such a vision as only the sheath hiding
the blade of shipbreaker bay with its
treacherous Tides unpredictable Gales
and sharp rocks lurking just below the
water's surface
the storms that blow through the Bay
Water the Kings wood and rainwood two of
the great forests of Westeros
and they give the stormlands their name
even without our weather we have more
than earned our name in strife
the first Storm King Darren started his
Reign by declaring war on the gods
themselves
he loved the daughter of the sea god and
the wind goddess but they forbade the
Union
at their wedding the gods unleash their
might pulling down his hold and killing
all of Darren's family and guests though
his wife shielded him
darn vowed to rebuild and when he did
the gods again destroyed his home his
counselors begged him to retreat Inland
but he would not abandon his War
finally with the Council of the children
of the forest or perhaps a young brand
the Builder Darren raised a seventh
castle that tries they might and still
do the Wind and Sea Gods could not tear
us under
Darren took the name God's grief and
called his new home Storm's end
having beaten the waters to the east
storm Kings turned their gaze to more
practical enemies the reach riverlands
and Dawn
for thousands of years the storm Kings
fought the gardener Kings of the reach
and various families of dawn for control
of the dornish marches just below the
red mountains
the fighting didn't stop until dawn
married into the Seven Kingdoms a mere
hundred years ago
still the houses of the stormlands such
as the dondarians guard the bone way the
mountain passed into the marches against
any dornish incursion
the storm Kings had greater luck to
their North at first
they took the Trident from the river
Kings and built an Empire that stretched
as far as the neck
but then the ironborn swarmed out of
their islands and pushed the storm Kings
out of the riverlands
no doubt the ironborn intended to expand
their empire into the stormlands before
they had a chance aegon Targaryen landed
with his dragons
while aegon burned the kings of the iron
Islands The Rock and the reach his
fiercest commander and rumored bastard
brother or his Baratheon set out to
subdue the stormlands
no matter how Fierce a warrior he was no
one could have entered his task storms
ended since thousands of years of war
and never fallen but argalak the Storm
King chose not to barricade himself
behind its walls and gave always the
battle he must have hoped for
auris slew argonac and took argalak's
Castle Kingdom daughter sigil and house
words
house Baratheon became the lord of the
stormlands
Targaryen rule quieted the stormlands
for the most part
until Robert rebelled against the Mad
King
his first challenge came not from the
crown but from his own Bannerman
tried to join
defeating three armies in a single day
at summerhall the victory cemented
Robert's control of the stormlands and
he was able to march on the reach and
riverlands with no enemy to his rear
yet not all of Robert's Bannerman sided
with him sir barrist and the Bold came
from the stormlands but as the
pre-eminent member of Eris kingsguard
and greatest Knight in the realm sir
barristan remained loyal after Robert's
decisive Victory on the Trident Robert
sent his own maester to care for his
countrymen sir barriston who had
suffered Grievous wounds whilst fighting
so hard to kill him
later when the king's Slayer betrayed
errors
Robert pardon sir barristan and even
took him onto his own kingsguard
when Robert lifted mace tyrell's
ill-managed Siege of Storm's end and
returned to his ancestral home he
realized the dream of all the storm
Lords before him to rule the Seven
Kingdoms
Rebellion
the crimes of House Targaryen were too
heinous to go unanswered
the noble houses of Baratheon Stark and
Aaron United to oppose and overthrow the
line of the cursed Dragon Kings
while Ned Stark and Aaron secured an
alliance with the tullys of riverrun
I called the banners of Storm's end and
rode out in force against the Mad King
and his minions
Gods those were some battles
our first Victory occurred at summer
Hall where I faced off against an army
of dragon Loyalists and won three
battles in a single day three in one day
seven hells that was a glorious day
we tried to take Ashford castle in the
reach but the tyrells beat us back
we had to regroup
my Army was pursued North by eris's Army
and took refuge in the Stony sept in the
riverlands
when the Targaryen Army entered the town
the sept Bells told a signal to the
townspeople and the battle that was to
come
as the Targaryen searched from house to
house for me the combined forces of Ned
Stark and the tullys swept into the City
Guards what a day that was
it's now known as the battle of the
Bells
we overwhelmed the Mad king's forces and
sent them scampering back to King's
Landing
aerys's son rhaegar who started the
whole damn thing finally emerged from
hiding in the South and assembled his
own Army to face us
as for the Mad King he must have been
pissing himself
the battle that would decide the fate of
the Seven Kingdoms occurred at the
Crossing of the green Fork of the
Trident River
rhaegar commanded the Royal host which
was some 40 000 strong
my forces were outnumbered by nearly
five thousand men
but that didn't matter
they were fresh
that we were battle-hardened and had
justice on our side
as the battle raged around as I faced
off with rhaegar the Stag and the dragon
right there in the fort of the river
I fought with the fury of Ten Men
reigning blow after blow up on that vile
Prince before Burying my Warhammer in
his chest
I hit him so hard the rubies on his
armor Broke Free flinging them into the
stream they call it the Ruby Ford now
with that scum rhaegar dead in the Royal
Army shattered our next move was to make
the King's Landing
but I'd sustained a few wounds in the
battle and was unable to ride
I sent Ned Stark to the capital to face
the Mad King and make him pay for his
crimes
as I said for free you can now listen to
the entire audiobook Fire and Blood On
which house of the Dragon is based and
which covers the entire Targaryen
history including current and future
events of House of the Dragon for free
with a notable trial using our Link in
the description
foreign